Oh!
I need to wait for it to go up, but I need to test if when I click live it instantly, like you can hear me?
Or if the thing is having a natural...
Oh...
I'm smelling away right now.
Good morning!
Good evening!
Good afternoon, you little fucks. That wouldn't let me win a Mario Kart.
Good morning, ladies and gentlemen!
How are ya?
How are you?
Hi, mommie.
Mommie?
Huh?
Hi, strongy.
Cha.
Mommie?
Hi, mommie.
Hello.
Hi, strongy.
I missed you, strongy.
Missed you too, Riefling.
Hey, wait.
Time to cry.
I probably hope not.
Hi, mommie.
Hi, Riefling.
I'm fine.
How are you doing?
I'm good.
Love, Riefling.
I hope you're doing good.
I'm glad you're doing fine.
Hi, mommie.
Hi, Riefling.
Well, I pleaded I was drunk at a friend's house and not there.
Hi, mommie.
Hi, Riefling.
Hey, strongy.
Hi, mommie.
Hi, Riefling.
Hello, mommie.
Hello, Riefling.
Hi, Riefling.
Yeah, this is over for you.
Hi, girls.
Hi, Riefling.
Hey, mommie and Riefling.
Hi, mommie.
Hi, Riefling.
Strongy.
Riefling.
I missed you and I haven't been able to watch you live.
It's been so depressing.
Aw, don't worry about it.
We're your busy bee.
Hello, strongy.
Hi, Riefling.
Hello, mommie.
Hi, mommie.
Hi, Riefling.
Hi.
Strongy, love.
Riefling love.
Thanks for the seratonin.
You're welcome for the seratonin.
Hello, mommie.
Hello, Riefling.
Hello.
Are you squidding me right now?
I've got my daily counter.
I am burning rage.
Gonna try writing this in your accent.
Hopefully, Brian, I'm nor being funny when I say I love your voice so much.
Whether ageing, sleepily mumbling, yapping, or sensually whispering are just wanna hear
it all the time, nay exceptions.
Wait, that Brian actually kinda spoke a bit of Scots there.
Now, oh no, no men there, Brian.
You got a bit twang to your accent there.
Thank you, Brian.
Kindly.
Thank you, tiny spiny for the tip.
Hi, strongy.
Hi, Riefling.
Thanks for babysitting me while she's being gone.
Hi, harem.
I'm in a car.
Hi, y'all.
Hi, harem.
Shebe's coming back soon.
Don't worry.
And then she's gonna milk you.
Did you get some sleep, mommie?
I got drumroll, please.
Seven hours, and I had a dream, and I've already forgotten the dream, but I do have an update.
I did the dad, I did my dad name's VTubers, and you're not ready, okay?
You're not ready for the stuff my dad came out with.
Oh my god, I did not expect it.
Is YouTube messing with your title or is it German?
No, it is a German meme where a guy goes, is it over for me?
But because of the way it looks in German, it's quite readable in English, so the sentence
is over for me, because apparently I'm gonna cry a lot in this game, so yeah.
Not the fully hours, but something, yes.
I did it with my dad.
Do you want to know what my dad's first comment about Azura's model was?
Because obviously I got him to react to my gen mates.
Just as a bit of a spoiler, my dad called Azura two fried eggs.
Now, we all know what he's referring to, because she has gold shielded plates on her front, right?
So he went, he went, her name's two fried eggs.
I was like, I did not fucking conceptualize Fondle of fucking Bism for two fried eggs.
I think I can't, off the top of my head, he called my model.
He obviously didn't recognize me, even though I've shown my, like I'm sure we've sat and watched me stream together.
And like we watched the Microsoft stuff and all that.
And he called me like a pink, pink knickers knee pants, and I was like, alright.
And then, and I was like, alright.
And she's also named after her dad's gamer tag anyway, Shonium.
And I'm like, yeah, I'll take it, Shonium, Shonium, yep.
I think, and then Mercy was the second one.
And he was like, he was like, Mercy, Mercy, Mercy.
Well, he never said Mercy, because he doesn't know anyone's name.
And he was like, oh my God, she's not got any knickers as well.
What's going on here?
And I was like, uh, I was like, no one's got a scar, no one's got knickers.
But you know what?
I was surprised about it.
He called Amy cute.
I was like, are you, are you fucking, are you nailed her design?
She's the most adored, knee knickers, literally knee knickers McGee.
And he went, oh, Amy's really cute.
And I went, damn straight, Amy's cute.
So, dad's a cunny Vtuber confirmed.
That's my little sister, yeah.
So cute.
And she's funny too.
It literally sounds like you're saying the M bomb.
Oh shit.
In Britain to say, uh, uh, under where we say that word.
And it probably sounds a bit funny in my accent.
I promise I ain't saying none of them.
That shit.
We don't tolerate that shit for around these partners.
Uh, is this a, is this a controller game?
What is this?
Right.
Before we get into the game.
Boom.
Tell me what you think.
Let me know.
Right.
No.
Are you squidding me right now?
Anonymous.
Anonymous says papa cuttles is becoming an Oni-chan.
Honestly.
He absolutely nailed AC.
Oh my God.
He went, she looks cold.
And I was like, yes.
And then he went, she looks like ace.
And I was like, yeah.
Like I was going, I was flipped.
I was doing backflips.
Cause there's no way that my dad would actually physically, you know, come up with the actual
names of the characters.
It's not possible.
But I got him to react to some other people as well.
I got him to react to project melody.
And oh my God.
So I showed them their reference sheets that has their names on them.
But my dad didn't know that that was their name.
So they didn't count.
And on her reference sheet, it said 69.
And he went, he went futuristic 69 girls.
For project melody.
And I was like, oh my God.
Yes.
Like, oh my God.
He like, we looked at Poseidon.
So if he didn't know Poseidon from Mythos just got a new model.
And I showed that off.
And I was a bit of a twat.
I actually said her name.
I was like, oh, she's based after the mythological God Poseidon.
And then he went, oh, X rated Poseidon.
And I was like, yeah, yeah.
I'll take that.
I'll let her name slip.
But I literally futuristic 69.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to get mock logos for whatever he said.
The girls finalized names are like, miss me from being you.
Oh, sorry.
Anonymous.
Thank you for the tip.
Hi, strong.
Have you been keeping up with work since you passed out?
Um, not quite.
But so right.
Let's go over the.
Let's go over the schedule.
Okay.
So again, there's three short streams, a little to the left, two hours, roller coaster, tycoon,
two hours, little kitty, big city, two hours.
And then hold on a minute.
What's going on on the 25th?
ASMR is back.
Memberships are back.
ASMR streams back on the 26th.
Then we've got a watch along of a mysterious video.
I'm going to say it as a friend.
We are going to watch a friend that is debuting.
And I said to do it for free.
So we're going to support a friend.
And if you like her, please.
You're more than welcome to give her a cheeky subscribe.
Don't be surprised.
I might, I might see an exchange for me watching you live on stream, my friend.
You have to do ASMR with me.
No, ifs ands or buts.
Okay.
When is the debut?
On the 26th at 10 p.m.
E.D.T.
Nope.
That's life of Brian Watchlong.
Sorry.
Try again.
On the 26th of Friday at 8 p.m.
E.D.T.
Mystery Watchlong.
And you don't get to know who it is.
No.
No, you don't.
Why do you?
And then next is who wants to be a millionaire.
But hey ho.
What's up?
Who wants to be a millionaire?
But hey ho.
What?
Wait, wait, wait.
What's the catch?
You get to see my heart rate monitor and I'm wearing my shock collar.
So every time I lose a round on who wants to be a millionaire, I get to shock myself.
Okay.
And then that gets followed into a member's ASMR where you see my heart rate and I shock
myself in the ASMR member's room as well.
And then old school RuneScape 99 Cooking.
Potentially we might be able to do it in one big 12 hour robot, okay?
Is it a little tight around the thigh area?
What do you mean you don't like my big fat lips?
Oh, the perfect.
We might be able to finish 99 Cooking, okay?
I am going to watch my gen mates in the background because I don't have time to watch them live.
So I'm going to pick two hour streams from each girl.
I'm going to do a little marshmallow thingy and that is our endurance beginning.
It is.
And what happens when we hit 99 Cooking?
We'll probably do some...
We'll give it a little break and then we'll come back and we'll actually just do some
questing because I've never actually properly done questing.
I did it with you guys for the first time properly and I want to do it again.
It was so fun questing and making sure like, come on, you know what it feels like?
It feels like I'm a teacher on a school trip with like a high vis vest on and like, come
on everyone.
No one gets left behind.
Make sure you've got your buddy.
Come together right next step.
I really enjoyed that.
So I'd like to do that again for the multiplayer game.
That is what's going to be considered the multiplayer game this week.
But yes, I'll have a bit of an update tomorrow.
About a few things behind the scenes.
We do love a few updates behind the scenes.
A few spoilers of the agency.
What do you mean agencies should hold freaking secrets?
I can't believe it.
You'll never get me.
You'll never take me alive.
Okay.
Right.
One thumbnail to show you.
Just one.
This is one thumbnail.
Spoilers from scrawny.
No way.
We're all open here.
When we get in her quick, her quest.
You know the answer to this one.
Are you sure?
What was as original and I've got phone a friend.
Let me see.
She be M.A. Marisa.
I could phone a friend for this question.
What was as original name?
Whole lot cleavage.
Grab them by the daddy.
We'll find out.
I love the news so much.
Answer Z.
I thought you guys would get a little giggle over that thumbnail.
Let me slurp my tea.
Has everything been going good?
I was quiet on the eastern front from my POV.
You guys haven't blown anything up while I've been away.
Someone says favorite game series you played on steam.
And are there any games you want to play but can't?
Any games I want to play but can't?
If you mean like from lack of skill?
Yes.
There's an insane amount of games that I want to stealing sea from my future YouTube career.
Do not call that.
That's terrible.
Fondalovism.
I'm such a good fucking name.
Everyone's rippin' into me for it.
Someone sent me a nexus mod for Skyrim but I'm too scared to open it.
Hey strongy.
I perceive this.
I hope that I don't have to explain why I'm showing this mod to you.
You want me to mod my Skyrim?
How dare you.
You don't want me to play vanilla Skyrim?
Okay.
Hi strongy.
Hi rippling.
Wanted to let you know your streams give me something to look forward to every day.
I feel like there's no amount of support that I can give that would adequately reflect a happy.
You do not have to give me anything.
Streaming isn't an exchange of goods and services okay.
I get to play my goofy games and then you get to be tormented by my goofy games.
And then everything is awesome.
We really are on the best timeline to have you look back after all that's happened.
I love you unironically.
I love you unironically too.
I'm glad you can enjoy what I put out.
I know I know I'm a bit special but my mummy caused me special too so it's fine.
Can't wait for the fangfully degenerate Skyrim theme.
I've been pondering the best way to say this so it's not too stupid.
This is the best I got.
I am not doing that short after the feedback I got.
So please don't worry.
I'm not going to do the short.
I didn't explain myself very well but long and short of it was basically.
Get tipped.
Thank you Spidey.
Not tiny Spidey.
You took infusion me.
What do you need to kiss because you both have the same name.
Well hold on a minute.
We ain't pin pals out here.
Hold on a minute.
Thank you Spidey for the tip.
I appreciate it.
What a short.
Okay.
I will explain it in a bit more detail because my thoughts weren't very straightforward.
Now here's the facts.
The Vealour announcement trailer has 100k thousand views on the Vealour YouTube channel.
Okay.
Now originally it was trending.
It was doing quite well.
I put some advertisement money into it but then we didn't actually need to have that much.
We had to, we could cancel them because a VTuber news covered us and then the video went trending
up to 100k views.
I was going to discuss a short about why the VTuber you watch might go absolute apeshit
if they make it on the VTuber news and it's because there's a correlation between new
eyes on you, new subscribers, new views, etc.
Okay.
I didn't explain it very well because my worry is that the channel you know is ran by a guy
and we follow idol culture but the focus wasn't about the guy.
The focus was like this is insider knowledge.
Like I was going to show you the graph from we got mentioned on this date and then you
see the graph and it just jumps right up type thing.
You know.
I've got nothing to have.
Oh I thought you were talking about making a short.
Yeah so that was what the short was about right?
And then I said please use Marshmallow for anonymous feedback because I know that not everyone,
you know you can't all reflect the shumer in one go type thing okay.
Hold on let me, let me slurp my teeth it's getting cold hold on.
But I've decided against doing it because I don't want to upset anyone and I know some
of you might be like oh that's perfectly fine because the focus isn't on that.
I don't want to alienate or upset anyone so I'm not going to.
So please don't worry okay.
Less than 20 minutes in and don't regret staying up for strong eight.
Oh that's so kind of you.
I'm gradually, me who's literally just rambling about Q&A stuff.
I'm not even freaking played the game.
I'm not even started.
Yeah.
Someone says I have an unexplainable desire to hear your voice through a phone mic maybe
a Twitter space or something.
Is that weird?
Maybe there's just something endearing about unprofessional quality.
I'm going to put an iPhone headphone up my butt.
Does that count for your unprofessional quality in the audio?
I mean it may.
It may.
Wait I thought you guys were seriously about wanting that.
I was going to do it.
I mean what did she say?
Can't get more unprofessional than that.
Turns into an iPhone mic.
Hold on let me slow it with you.
That 360 mic that you could use.
Do it for science.
I'm with the science team.
You mean an AirPod?
No like it would be on the strings because I don't want to get lost up there you know.
Are you squidding me right now?
I would like talk to you while sitting inside you.
To be fair you could just ramble and I'd still love the stream.
I'm not like a Zatsun streamer.
I need like a mission objective.
Thank you Broly Legends for the super chat.
I need like a mission objective or else I can't do that.
When I was playing the Watamelin game this week or however you say it.
Why is the title German?
Hello, what's up?
Or did you not know I am German VTuber?
I love the schnitzel.
I like game spelling.
What's that?
You're just saying Dutch in front of German words.
I'm substituent.
Oh my god yes.
How did you not know that with my accent I am German?
Sorry I have fooled you.
I play prank on you.
Not Scottish at all.
You have been pranked.
That's right in your face.
You've lost your job.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Have a confession.
When you were making strange sounds and teasing me right now.
I was joking.
Okay well I'm not going to read that one out loud.
Sorry.
Broly legend.
Thank you for the super chat.
Mission objective survived as that.
I didn't know where that was going.
I apologize as soon as I said that.
I'm sorry.
I always find VTubers in an accent so pleasant.
I listen to ASMR side.
The streams make me so sleepy.
Oh no.
Oh wait.
What's my harsh accent?
Oh no you're falling asleep aren't you?
Go to sleep.
My weedy friend.
Oh!
A strong aid.
You keep teasing at the start games and encouraging
throwing to let you win.
It's going to give me an interest and wouldn't see it.
Ah yeah you're supposed
so i love you love you terry fling
hello stroney hello riffling come on bubble let's go party this might be an odd message but i just
got done watching your sevika game and i just wanted to sorry i can't i can't maintain the
freaking song and the syllable and i just wanted to say it's been so much fun watching you stream
and game i thought it was like the worst stream so far honestly when you say oh and the other
sounds you make are so cute that make all the sense i don't know why but when i hear them they
always make me smile never feel bright not my day i just want to thank you for being so cute no thank
you for fending me cute amma that make all the sense all the time are you guys gonna get in complex
is this real real real real true now i'm wondering if you can do a vikin accent uh i can do i used
to be able to do the skyrim accent what someone stole your sweet roll add maybe needless to the
female skyrim guards um hi stroney i just want to tell you that i love you i love you too and you
always brighten up my day get bright and get bright and get bright i just want to give you
lots of hugs and kisses kisses now do the pizza actually did you just say italian accent is called
the pizza accent i think we flin i think our brain rods are getting a bit too strong with this one
right i must finish my t's 20 minutes oh my god
skyrim belongs to the north i said what i said sorry i honestly don't know how anyone goes
i want to be with the rebellion
we it's clearly the storm am i going crazy in skyrim sorry could we discuss skyrim politics for a
minute how the fuck is it not stormcloaks i don't know what everyone's like this is the other side
are the stormcloaks are rascist uh if fucking elves start coming into my country being like
you're not allowed to start praising talus anymore uh get fuck out my country then go back to your
one that praises your fucking dae like fuck off like sauce i don't know how this rascist sauce
skyrim politics is bizarre it's actually bizarre i don't know how anyone doesn't see these like
lay out of it honestly anyway no enough of that before i start getting angry
they did the argonians in the dunwar i always face the bay i'm like what's happening here i'm
currently fighting with people that aren't real as i naturally do i apologize i'm reading
a few marshmallows and then we're going to get into this game apparently i'm going to greet my
little heart out so totally not stalling and try to finish my tea honestly it's so hard to finish my
tea okay one gulp two three four i'm gonna okay i did it i finished the tea goodbye tea it was nice
doing you um strawney fighting ghosts and the problem isn't that the imperials and high elves
that's what are going in and drama which treat the animals uh hi strawney hi me thing thank you so
much for bringing us everyone in veal oh no you're welcome thanks to you you're giving me so many
laughs and good time even through the six girls i've finally found an oh she and i can't be watching
because of you yes even though i didn't support each of us very much i now have you as my oh she
and azura as my kami yes yes yes mama oh yeah wait how can't there a voice wait hold on i would love
both my mama azu and mommy strawney giving me tingles and bed at night azura giving me positive
affirmations calling me a good boy and strawney squeezing me right now brian and my blood
skyrim is for mama and the true route is to go imperial but do the full dark brotherhood
questline for maxima manaki and now a good end strawney teasing me and my and how obedient i am
for mummies i love you strawney i love you too little bleeding heart are you squiddling me right now
what's that i'm skin walking is my genie it's so scary thank you jimmy poor cynic i'm so sorry
that's not how you say that at all we love you strawney we love you wavelength thank you for the
extended membership and thank you milk cadmus why the tip okay should i need to i want to see your
hands around my thing it would look huge uh it's first thing in the morning and we're we're about
to play the most depressing game of all time are you are you okay biflin stronzo i apologize for not
sending too many h word maros please believe me when i say every day i want to squeeze me right now
well can't read that one up uh garfunkel not to be confused with garfield thank you for the
extended membership you you didn't put a message in you could have put a little message in that box
the other made me realize i have a thing for a smart good because uh we have like so many
ace work all apps coming out together so it's all just me as i'm sorry you have to find out
right i really right we're gonna jump into the game
that was quick oh oh i can look around oh there's a backpack oh no i don't know what
oh you just finished i have no idea what this is
click zoom in oh i'm i'm opening and closing the book it won't open i'm holding the mouse
i'm going to click the mouse again and we're putting it back okay point and click to a book
open sim and you later stop i literally can't figure out how to open it i'm great so this is left mouse
click and i keep that right mouse click is to zoom in you gotta drag it open oh shit okay
going to make sense to you and i'm sorry about that i'm just going to start at the beginning
with the house is that loud enough for you guys
is that loud enough filtered by the title screen literally couldn't even get into the game
you guys didn't tell me this was the next like dark so until i was 11 but i wasn't allowed inside
half the rooms okay oh my god i don't have to read it's a little quiet i mean i can
i put it up by a whole four decibels ooh is this our mailbox oh that's so cute right hold on i'm
pulling inside the mailbox we got that from seven years ago marked urgent open immediately
okay oh i ran out of mouse my space to do that hold on let me just move this piece of paper
to the side i have notes on it from my dad i was like jesus presiding for nipples i hadn't been back
since my brother lewis is funeral a damn loose pop is closed i'm sorry hear that
but again oh no trespassing this property is protected by video surveillance trespassers
will be shot on side you know where is it
in her will my mother left me a key but didn't tell me what i've unlocked
now when you see your local maybe she thought i'd know
or she thought the mystery would be enough to bring me back
one odd game i didn't know what to expect i thought this was going to be like one of them pixel
things honestly reeflings this might be the farm if we went a bit more foresty i think those are
called uh i forgot the name of them strap i know what the name of those are time to cry again
we've driven this way in a long time but i saw if you have prints who's prints so we've we have
horses no any horse troopers oh it's a deer hello
oh my god this game is beautiful what the heck i did not expect any of this
i thought it was gonna there's this sad game that the truth is
even after i inherited the house i never thought i'd come back to it so everyone's dead in my lineage
but now i had questions about my family but only the house know the answers to
curious the house was exactly like i remembered it the way i'd been dreaming about it
what
i'm intrigued this does not look up to code the child the house made me uncomfortable in a way
i couldn't put into words i am i'm intrigued i have curious you had my you had first you had
my curiosity now you have my attention now as a 17 year old i knew exactly what those words were
i was afraid of the house what
i hope the key might unlock the front door it didn't
looking in i felt like the house itself had been waiting for me
what's that movie where the house was alive monster house
okay let's go to the left because this is a garage
it's osha certified they came through there like yeah this is fine
that house looks like it's gonna fall down oh they got winching
i'm the dog oh i was joking oh i was joking but going through the doggie door used to be a
lot easier when i was 11 uh okay i thought we were gonna like reach what is it a tennis ball
oh is that to tell you if you're going in too far or something i then it wouldn't be the first time
in years i felt like i was home all refunds imagine if we had a lovely picture but instead of a
family there were just memories of one that's a lot of fish wait um and it spins as well it's
like a captain's reel and oh look at the hob this is big money hob this big might be money
like how only one restaurant would deliver to our house so we had chinese a lot
love a good chinese on a Saturday
okay i'm not i'm not gonna get jumped in the house looked abnormal there was just
too much of it like a smile with too many teeth it's a hobbit hole what do you
save the barks for your collar born puppy
it's strange
great grandpa spenn built music parks for barbara along with the house
barbara finch was the director oh my god the boo
boo
mama always told me to stay out of the basement so i wasn't too surprised when the key didn't fit
okay so the key doesn't fit let me see i mean it's not really god look at the views
reef like could you imagine yeah even the fireplace had a story eddie told me the bricks
came from the original house after it sank i like the missing bricks at the top
the table was still a wreck from the night we left
the night you live my mom was the only one of us who could imagine it was like a bomb had gone off
killing everyone but sparing the furniture what
it's
i'd rather come puzzling right we've been in the kitchen
okay let's see why so much fish after louis started working at the cannery we all got
pretty sick of salmon oh except our cat molly molly
wow
wait wait isn't that the bonded stuff that stops
oh they won't let me use it she shall see how it is after mountain disappeared mom sealed up all
the bedrooms oh then eddie retaliated and drilled peep holes
calvin my grandpa sam spent seven years sharing a room with his dead brother calvin
well like the corpse was just being chilling or
as a kid i just assumed every house had peep holes and sealed rooms you weren't allowed inside of
the dates are how long they survived greggory was one calvin was a living what
it's
the last time i was in edith senior's room i was 10 and she was painting my portrait
we still have a key but we need a room to go inside of
whenever people ask me about my family the first thing they always want to know about is barbara
okay
jeez barbara's room let's go
greggory from barbara was a child star for two years until america grew out of it
wait for two years won't she never let it go eddie's father odin built the original house
uh-huh wait where do you put this key now am i strong enough mom must have locked
34 stairs on the night left how how peculiar this game is i'm not sure what to make it over
yet i spent a lot of time playing in great uncle walters room i think my mom sometimes
regretted not sealing it up it looks good looks good to me told me there were secret passages but
i never believed him oh progress 20 000 leaks under the sea my mom was really good at keeping secrets
oh i was going to find out what my mom had been afraid of
what could be in a house that's so bad from the paintings on the wall it was clear my brother
milton had been here before me
the pot set oh reading this maybe it sounds like i had a plan but i had no idea what was behind the
door the bedroom i cute one of those like i had no idea where all this was gonna lead
why did we yelly fish it's metal i grew up looking at molly's room through the peephole
okay molly's got a molly finch a diary
december 13th 1947 dear diary i'll be gone soon but i wanted to tell somebody about what's gonna
happen it started when mom sent me to bed without dinner i woke up and i was starving so i looked
around for something to eat her hamster's food the gerbil the gerbil food was dry but i didn't mind it
that's a shame i guess mom's a bit bipolar than any
my halloween candy was all gone
and you can't go out can you mom can i come out now
don't sleep okay are you squidding me right now
anonymous weekend hi strani i wanted to recommend a movie what about 40 meters down to women get
trapped in a cage 40 meters full sea levels around fish that's very specific oh you're gonna
okay no no we're not gonna eat the freaking goldfish that's a bit much
young child is she gonna eat the goldfish
no okay she's not molly molly i thought i honestly thought why are you dissecting starfish
feel that shit right i kept eating and eating oh i'm not toothpaste you can't eat that it's got
fluoride in it you spit toothpaste out when you're finished with that thank you for the
tippy fling cubie i'm gonna guess that's how i say thank you for coming to member oh
i ate a lot of things that night
oh that's gonna kill her what the hey is this pure poison
my nasty mom then i heard chirping outside my window hello little birdie
it was a barn swallow going back to her nest i reached out for her
oh we're locked in and suddenly
i was a cat
she did
i tried to be quiet but the bird was really scared
i'm coming for you
mom and dad didn't even look at me
okay okay
i'm coming for you now go for the eggs the babies were all gone oh we have to chase the bird
dying
oh the cat's got a collar on her i almost got her
i don't i don't believe in collars for cats
i could tell she was getting really tired the cat or the bird
now i was up in the big tree i promise that i wouldn't climb it anymore
all i cared about was eating that mama bird
i gobbled her up
and suddenly i was an owl first all i heard was the wind
then i heard little teeth nibbling in the grass a mouse it will go for mouse
where
rabbits i missed that was a terrible aim bro go back up i heard it
okay now snake us i don't imagine his face looking up and seeing mine through my
house i swallowed him up and i didn't shoot one
bigger than a rabbit i mean
a mama rabbit
oh
jeez i really don't know what to think yet
uh
i rolled off a cliff and into the ocean now i was hungrier than ever
oh shit it's like wasd controls but w makes me like look up
oh
this is bizarre truly i wanted that juicy serious
i tore off her flipper and it tasted really good where did it go
well i guess they go away what the hell there is
oh
it's got a wee tentacle reef lenses this is the longest one i've done
and i just like keep moving now i was a monster and i smelled people
i'm eating people
my pov is this tentacle in your room
i don't know where i'm going
lower accurate real
i was big but i moved real quiet
oh i have more
the camera angle is plugged in there go up them stairs please
i'm eating the whole boat i wanted to stop but also i didn't
oh
someone is there i don't know someone's up there how do i get up in
here
this passenger i was still hungry and across the water
he swam to me and it's something i had to have so i swam towards it
i'm not gonna lie i don't really see where the parm's supposed to start crying out
i slithered onto the sand and the good smell went into an old pipe
pov me after the reef ones have ran a train
that's not funny don't laugh at that that was a terrible joke terrible tent to humor and stop
i was literally toilet humor but i'm right i'm in a bathroom
okay
i got closer and closer oh she's gonna eat herself well metaphorically her body
ate itself i guess is the i literally cannot see her i assume she's on the bed
all my stomach all my stomach started growling her body ate itself i assume it's what
i held my breath for a long time but i couldn't hear anything
i think it's waiting for me to fall asleep but it's not going to wait much longer
found it needs to be and we both know i will be delicious
i'm not sure if i believed all of that but i'm sure edie would have
uh
how bizarre this would be obvious later but my mom never told me any of these stories
edie would have but mom didn't like bringing up the past
though when we adopted a stray kitten uh-huh she was the one who named it molly
but okay let's go in the window i spent a lot of time in great grandma edie's room
her room was like a museum
for 500 years the finches have been famous throughout norway for their over norwegian and
misfortune
odin finch buries the latest victims of the family curse his wife inga borg and their newborn son
yohan
on january 7th 1937 he set sail with his family and his house hoping to leave the curse behind
but 40 foot waves off the coast of washington send the house and odin to the bottom of the sea
um odin's daughter edie with husband spin and baby molly step ashore on their new home
orcas island
odin finch is the first to be buried in the new family cemetery
his daughter edie is already dreaming of a new finch house
um i'm not sure what on air oh sorry i meant to like
i died back out tab escape no escape is play okay space bar no
oh i'm stuck i'm stuck oh no what button is it shift control alt space bar enter
a b c d f g h i j i k l m n i'm actually stuck e normally eat a back out all effort you don't
what you're done for um um um i actually stuck hold on right p for page got it
i just keep press s how did you know that reefland oh my god literally saved me what the
fuck whatever's wrong with this family it goes back a long ways okay that you actually saved us
you unironically saved us thank you reefling can i unlock from this side
no i can't curious right we've got an oxygen supply we've got our monday meds Tuesday meds
remember to take your med lewis died a week before we left but edie had already started to memorialize him
oh
what does he call edie knit me a new pair of gloves every year just in time to replace the old ones
that's why she's got gloves on
all f4's ultimate cure to the games one summer they evacuated the island but edie refused to go no
because then you'll this is what that's she was a celebrity i'm will edie won't go 72 year old
woman refuses to vacate because of a little boy a little forest bar never heard anyone built 1937
ovin fiends yaw ovin he told people spen was killed by a dragon she could also have said he
was building a dragon shaped slide that collapsed she could have but she didn't
no i'll wait to go out dragon kills bench tragedy strike so it's a no way even in your 90s
sometimes edie seemed a lot younger than my mother and my mother oh is that carpet
oh carpet in the bathroom
oh poor thing she couldn't sit in the bathroom the only trace grandpa sam's first wife k left on
the house was the pink bathroom
no it was a pretty big trace
oh wait the key unlocks everything
imagine having books walked around the house and no having an inclination there might be something
there the real good open i'm there's a secret in this bathroom uh-huh it's in the last place you
would look it isn't in the cupboard it's hidden in this book okay how curious i'm still not sure
what to make of this game have the majority of you played this is this like one of those games
gave sam an old camera he'd refurbished he never put it down
he developed photos red light
no i'm not doing exactly what you think i'm doing
never seen it no only watched a video on it
explore the universe
it's just a story we feel visuals don't you agree is there anything over here that's
supposed to do is this like i do not cross does he pop his bogs
oh i was gonna jump down on it but i guess not uh right there's something i knew grandpa sam had a twin
and that he never talked about him so the command center
i guess my grandpa didn't like history anymore than my mom did
how i want to remember my brother by sanfinch the thing i remember is that one he made up his
mind that was it i broke his we foot
my brother said he'd die before you another mushroom and he did
at barbara's funeral we swore he'd never be afraid again and he wasn't
i think calvin always wanted to fly
that day he finally made up his mind to do it
i told him going around was impossible
maybe if i hadn't said that
forget are we going to do a circle let's go
maybe it's the one time i'm picked up
tell the one i can do the circle and maybe
oh shit i'm about to kill him wait a moment he's already made up his mind
that's why i remember about my brother
i think i'm about to pop his bogs if he does a circle hold on
this
hey
did he know learn to swim
what
it calvin's story felt strangely familiar
when i was younger i remember trying to do the exact same thing
a stony there's rocks below okay okay sorry okay i'm too slow for this game i think
okay right okay i may have just perished that child but you can't prove it
okay oh he's got to be plaque thing in here like that wife draws
after the funeral oh eddie roped off calvin's house the room
oh roped off okay i understand the company mom said grab a sam enlisted at 18 and
never set foot in the room again oh i went into the army
the hungry caterpillar or something
oh what is that i looked a bit too
made
wait all the finches have popped their clogs but me the passages were a pretty tight fit
they'd obviously been built for smaller hands and bellies
okay that's the hallway right that's fine you're the last finch alive i believe it
growing up i always thought of barbara as a child star
okay i never thought about how hard it must have been for her afterwards
i hear that some people get a very unique complex after stardom is over
the thing moldy do not eat that she can't even eat yeah like stardom can cause like
you some you know very strange
of all the stories people wrote about barbara's death i'm surprised eddie saved this one
why is it real
old jack here with another ghastly tale inspired by america's most unfortunate family
i'm calling it the surprise ending of barbara rich
as a child star barbara was famous for her screen
now at 16 she was all washed up her has been
but in a lucky break she'd been asked to perform her signature scream at a local convention for
monster movie fans it was just the boost
unfortunately her scream hadn't aged where
me i think you just need the right motivation her biggest fan
either or was about to demonstrate when
now that is that will help it was barbara's father saying he'd slipped into a table saw
and had to be rushed to the emergency room so barbara that stuck babysitting her youngest
brother walter a convention comeback was cancelled
okay i'm hearing frustration but i'm not hearing terror what if i tried a gang of hoodlums
in halloween mass have been terrorizing orca's island tonight police are urging residents
that came from the basement you're right i came for the basement i loved your delivery on that
why is your basement door locked because my dad likes making puzzles and secret passages
there's a key hidden in the music box the secret is to keep winding and winding
until finally the key pops out thanks babe i'll be back in a sec
and we know what to do rick hadn't returned so barbara remember that story i'm writing it down
right on q
she reached for the music box
am i doing an encomic
they really want to tell you where the key is
she found a mix scratch and imagined the worst
the gang's leader is the infamous hook man killer dr carl hamlin who unveiled in an eight
his family 10 years ago tonight
okay
barb relax i was just trying to scare you to help you find your screen well i'm not scared rick
i'm furious then act furious all i'm getting from you now is that you're hurt and confused
she threw him out but you kept the little something to remember him barb crutch have
you seen my other crutch and she was still holding it when she fell asleep watching the
late late picture show hours later barbara walter what's going on up there
okay i'm coming up but if this is a trick we're dead
uh continues all right we'll be walking
a roller plate
let's care of the
halter are you there
wow
vanished
huh
orca's island police describe the man as six feet tall with a steel hook for a hand
resident search of all doors and windows and notified the police of any suspicious activity
oh i'm getting drunk
this is how she pops her clothes
oh he went like there's gotta be another way out of here he went like crazy
she played our part beautifully
well is this our last rule type of idea
right that's a bathroom
oh sorry forgot sorry wait
let me go out
beam the fuck up
yeah
right we need to beat him up literally gang violence him
the the rules are off i don't care if he's passed out we're beating him in smithereens
i want to see brain matter i'm not finished until we see brain matter did i make myself clear
no
okay who's at the door we don't see you
i'm inside the house
oh we're getting oh dear oh dear
what
she saw what kind of monsters they were and she realized what was about to happen
i know brandy Barbara Finch gave the performance of her life
i wasn't there myself but i hear Barbara was magnificent
poor girl she had a taste for stardom but unfortunately so did her fans
of course the police blamed it all on poor rick who disappeared the same night
and little walter hiding under his bed the whole time he took it all pretty hard
but that's another story as for Barbara tucked inside the music box is all they ever found of her
her
oh now that's what i call a real fear retail
oh that was good
that was very unique that one he told me all Barbara wanted was to be remembered
as absurd as that comic was maybe what edie saw was a happy ending
how
okay so we know we need to go to the music box
but we can't unlock these doors we need to go back in the ear on the back the end
boo that joke sucks i guess now i know my mom doesn't like me playing with the music box
what oh what rub an eerie tale
there we go we got them in 40 i've already forgotten what the box unlocks uh oh the basement
the basement the basement i remember it's all about reading between the lines of this game
what is your guess and how she died um i need to read oh god i have to think wait a minute i
thought i didn't have to think in this game keep going keep going keep going keep going hey big
hey we uh she died a ligma you know what that's funny but you're not allowed to say that
okay we're in the boss mints any basement dwellers i dwell the basement in fact i am the biggest
basement dweller of law i was like a bit the idea of a basement but they're not a thing
mom said the basement was off limits unless i wanted another tetanus shot
sudden not living disease the shift oh these are the bases of where we put our dead family
members faces on hmm what were you making you were making a dragon concept of the sleigh they guess
that's where he messed up his hand i saw eddie sneak down to the basement once
carrying packages what kind of packages right let's see what's in the fridge she was hiding
presents what's in the fridge oh turned out she was hiding a lot more than that can i go in please
i can hardly see nothing don't worry if you can't see nothing i can't see nothing either
we're in the same boat here because my name i remember asking mom once about where walter had
gone we have a main shaft under the house he got as far away as he could
we got folly bunker oh this is kind of cool stories down here wait one
anonymous careful i think mercy's hating the dead senpai's down here you leave mercy out of
she made i think it's that none of us has gotten very far wait this is so cool though sorry this
is cool yes walter walter white i like everyone just have a goodbye everyone oh i can't believe i've
been down here for 30 years he just rolled on that first day after the shaking started i didn't
think i survived
oh i lived as a hermit but after a few days i settled into a routine that's what kept me sane
having a stable living for today
mm mango they always expected to be dead tomorrow
January 1976
here i was rumbling they're tumbling but let me adjust on my chair and putting my feet up
even a monster on the other side of the door starts to feel normal
almost friendly did he have agriphobia and you couldn't go outside
and then one day everything just
2005 yes whatever that thing was it was gone maybe you got tired of waiting
he thought maybe i just got tired of being afraid
ate too much peaches and died of confusion got botchers and via cans it's been a week now
the longest in 30 years uh-huh i'm done waiting i have to leave well i still can okay okay let's
this let's do it let's do it
play easily easy we're an old man i don't call much exercise in this
i know it's out there somewhere
whatever killed barbra
murder the cat
any break the wall maybe this is all a mistake with sleigh time or no shovel
but i need to stop living the same day even if it kills me
whatever's out there i want you to know i'm ready for it
this is a train track so that explains the shaking i'm going to appreciate all of it especially the food
i don't mind if i only have a year left why have we got a timer for a month
maybe we should get up a train track
yeah i can already imagine the sun
i mean
yeah
walter died when i was six i can't believe my mom never told me he was down here
a truly a cursed family honestly
i'm sure my mom was trying to protect me
is this like a window yeah i was actually really smart sorry that's really smart
little plywood behind there you could say he followed his train of thought
oh okay i mean look i'm just trying to bring light to the game like relaxed
do we use the letters dolti
maybe she was afraid i'd end up like walter
he went a little off the rails
but if she might call me about an uncle under the house
i can only imagine what else she was hiding
it's like all his supplies just been showing me i guess
i don't want to make the same mistakes she made
trying to bury something that's still alive
i think that i have the only one of us left or maybe two i think i have the emotional
intelligence of like a jellyfish because am i supposed to be crying no i wonder i think if
you because you told me i would be sad
yeah i found out what happened to everyone else i think you just told me it was sad my
brain's like proper prepared but now i'm worried the stories themselves might be the problem
i know my brain is over prepared maybe we believed so much in a family curse we made it real
oh it's just me memorial
kind of like later or anything
just experience but okay okay okay i i know over i don't know if i should even be writing this
you can write what you look
light head
maybe it'd be better if all this just died with me
me a bit more bits a bit more of a silent a bit more bits but i thought you should know about
your family who i'm a finch and the history you're a part of the monka family curse the
monka one to be honest i feel as lost as you probably do right now
i think the people in these stories believed them for what that's worth
me
okay i can look at the house yeah that history of imagination and stubbornness and madness
any of it seems possible
i was gonna say that game keeping anything out it's for accessory
i think we've been surrounded by death for so long we've just gotten used to it
i am going to do one thing what kind of family finishes building a cemetery before starting the
house no is that real oh that's rough it's embarrassing for me to admit this but
that's rough the cemetery may be more uncomfortable than the human one
three of the gerbils are mine and two had been my fault
zui's derpy lurpy furpy chirpy burpy derpy derpy junior lucid easy charlie tucker co-co-rip
and bailey of course oh wait is bailey a person i think bailey may be a person
oh there's another one bob shadow oliver christopher
what
spend up the house but it was edie who designed the cemetery
oh i get you i was a look in the past the cat was a past
oh that's adorable wait did they all have that no they don't hey you be
ah i'm not smart enough oh right she got her own star i'm sure odin's monument had been edie's idea
my mom was always trying to move on but three the past never went away
she's thinking how
she could see it poking out of the water at low tide
that's the previous house
magalek's one edie said she dreamed about the old house every night
oh it's got a caution boy that goes in the water
did anything else
was this supposed to be anything hope not
the old house and all that was wrong
edie's side was always easier for me to understand
yeah
but the older i get the more i can see where my mom was coming from
her dad had been pretty strict but it wasn't enough to save her brothers
she was just trying to do better
she lost two of her brothers just like i did i get why she tried so hard to protect us
got so far we never found melton's body so my mom insisted we were putting up a monument
not a tombstone we never found a body aren't we about to come across the skeleton
there's so many things i wish i could ask my mom now part of me thinks this is what she wanted
all along for me to come back someday and find everything out for myself
this wood is fantastic they don't make wood like this anymore
this has been years in the making and it's still stable and all but looking back on it now
if she told me there was going to be so much climbing
i never would have come when i was 22 weeks pregnant
oh is she your prego you're 17 and 22 weeks pregnant hold on a minute i thought you were 17
the book is to the child that she's pregnant with she's telling the family history to the
wane and her bailey i never met her as him but i think he and my mom had a lot in common
well it chilled up for a very short lifespan
they were both pretty intense
whoa my oh she caught me was she so smart so they aren't cursed they're just stupid honestly i
felt that on my personal level
eh i'm cooking perfect food don i promise you'll never forget this weekend yes sir
these memories are gonna last a lifetime oh don't do that again am i gonna have to shoot anything
it's a hunting trip don shooting is strongly encouraged what
right everyone close your eyes three two one ah perfect
it's gonna rain the whole weekend isn't it
i'll tell you when to close your eyes don't worry right close your eyes three two one
please just take the damn picture what picture hey language i will never forget this weekend dad
that's the spirit but three two one okay got it i'm gonna take some pictures okay just be careful
the camera's older than you are
definitely should not have drunk all that coffee
hmm should i take a poll hey
that's a keeper yeah okay oh that's what we're supposed to take a poll
i'm not always gonna be here don you'll need to remember this stuff if you want to survive
i'll be fine dad you know who else thought he was gonna be fine
some guy who died don i'm being serious i know dad three two one doesn't being out here make you
want to chill out right three two one been out here in 20 years
isn't it it's not what's the subject
thank you is it the birds last time i was with my brother calvin dad good eyes don three two one
before you take the shot let me get a picture of you
um dad i three three two one
no don you don't have to do anything if you want to survive you'll need to be strong three two one
um great shot don uh not quite
no you're not taking a picture of your crying daughter wait i can like hardly zoom in three two one
i'm proud of you don always remember that oh my god i'm like controlling him
are you bro comfort your door wait like i don't know go dad it's twitching i think it's totally
normal though just focus on the camera try not to think about dad
um
all these stories that's the one i wish most that my mom had told me
the revenge of nature
traumatizes daughter in 4k literally Sam spent his life shooting photos but mom said he got
nervous being in front of the camera i guess we're all afraid of something
see that we door there i'm just gonna check instead of hiding from dad
sam seemed to go out of his way to meet it god
mitten's worth his attack in the foot out of that squirrel oh my god he'd be in it he'd be in his
ass
i'm just gonna check there's nothing
this is the astronauts twin brother the one that's in
you
after sam died my mom and eddie got really close they'd both lost a lot
i have just mom and eddie oh my god they shat
sorry i'm just seeing how it is
Gregory you're in the vents you're acting so
oh the baby oh no the baby popped its clogs so young what happened
and the baby got taken in the divorce
dear k do you remember the way Gregory used to laugh when he thought he was alone
like something funny was happening but only he could see it schizophrenia and childhood
i got barbie oh he drowned
i think there's some things the rest of us don't
the child drowned
oh the child drowned you're never to leave a child unattended in a bar
children cannot pull themselves off
and over Gregory it's time to
don't get distracted mommy i'm in the tub
oh no
fam i told you i don't want to talk right now
oh he's gonna reach forward in his whole ugar can you
build a plug mr frog that'd be great
oh no
oh my god no
oh
yeah this is gonna be sad i can't actually see it
as he saw the wheel we'll get the wheel
oh sorry hold on let me get the wheel
i can't reach it with the heck
wait i need to jump in between the duck
it sure made him happy
okay progress
do you want the wheel
you're the wheel no the wheel's over by you
i have zero clue i'm supposed to
oh
oh more friends
i know how silly it sounds
but i worried about a baby being too happy
so
sorry about that Gregory
i know you did everything you could
wait i didn't try maybe if i hadn't called that
i don't want
he did drone
i hate
so
can we pull it
oh
good luck k love sam
oh my god
that was a bit brutal i have to admit
cool that was brutal
oh
never leave a child i can't imagine my mom ever writing poetry and yet
i had a an acquaintance she wasn't a friend like i didn't know her like that and she had a five-year-old
and he was having a bubble bath on his own and you think five-year-old would be fine
don't worry nothing happened um but she went away she literally that's that's exactly what
happened she went away on a phone call and she came back and he went mummy almost drowned
and she's like what do you mean pull yourself up because you know there's handlebars on the
side of the bathtubs and he was like i just couldn't the bath was too slippery and uh yeah
she was like really freaked out because he was five years old you thought he was old enough to
like have a bath by his own but it just goes to show like that stuff's dangerous like it's so
dangerous i'm so serious about that so you can't even um a poem for gus who always said the wedding
was a bad idea our father never hit us kids at least not very hard before the day my brother said
with teenage disregard that he'd be dead before he'd see a wedding in our yard
so
people can drown in an inch of war yeah like there's there's no frame or reason why someone
my father made him come of course but gus stood far apart just flew his kite and bottled up the
storm inside his heart
it's like a co-sleeping with a baby
we don't need a stepmom or the words
i now pronounce you husband and wife you make him cry
not the cemetery overlooking the fucking wedding because you don't enjoy it
got that tiki statue actually it makes me want to play view of up in y'all
i can't see right now
one so 360 360 enemy scv above
i'm gonna poke him with a kite yeah take that uh i don't want to step mom take that
what am i supposed to do
we don't want to step mom so let's stop her in the eye with the kite then
okay message evil oh
ready i was not the time for photos came dad ordered him to come here
but gus declined and as a sign held up his middle finger oh
oh
i hear gis wind picked up and panic gis appeared and quickly went but all the humans did that day
was go inside the tent a wave
they're going inside the gazebo
oh
right look for the secret gray layers
this is really sad
oh there they are
oh there is a hurricane
a hurricane
okay not yet not yet not yet
oh we're a lot faster as well
oh
i don't need all of it oh no we just need all of the
thunder sounded much too close and full of angry power
but all my father said to this was make the music louder
oh this can be
so
i wish that i could truly say i thought about you on that day
out there on the beach alone just you the wind see and phone is this the one where the body
we couldn't find but i didn't until we found no
yeah they're curse sorry they're cursed why would you get pregnant don't be so selfish
boy they were going to be me gus
what we got two more oh no three more my apologies those are three more
ah i'm not gonna be lying if you knew your family was cursed don't be selfish and have
a child question mark is it that hard i don't know uh you know your life doesn't end if you
don't spawn in a little fucking crotch goblin like yourself or anything
we claim we can't claim my mom moved up to the loft after her brothers died
this kill streak is unbelievable literally i'm about to be able to call an attack so far away she
could get
dawn all these notes oh my god this is literally what my uh desk is like i have notes scribbled
everywhere it honestly looks crazy because it's like emmy this azura that mercy this uh she be
that like that's what all my notes look like around my desk it's just all the girls names
screw oh no don't go down i just claimed all right let's try that again like i just i needed
the exercise okay i needed the exercise i needed the exercise it's fine it's fine let's go again
okay okay well i just wanted to you know make sure i'm ready for my 3d debut you know
yeah well pull action
she spent a summer building houses in kakata where she met my dad son j
what did you say my mom moved to india a week after graduation and got a job teaching english
louis was born a year later oh they fell in love and they kissed me
when my dad died i don't think mom knew where else to go i'm sure eddie was happy to have her back
the house had to get a little can i impregnate you where did that come from
um
and for a while lots of school things were good almost normal great job
analyze objectively never stop learning assume nothing which make criticism as
oh this is like a proper oh there's a gerbil cage
too a medurable put it in last
scientific method observation question research hypo sun hypothesis experiment data conclusion
to teach and to learn don't think
speak your truth brother beginning of the end was melton's 10th birthday when eddie gave him a castle
we're looking the people melton there's no death the only thing he left behind was a room full of
paintings there's no death notice that there's no death number
so
you sure got us with a lock
who's that so nice oh they're very nice
i think eddie was happy to finally have another painter in the family
i do not have that kind of strength i'mma tell you that right now i do not have that kind of strength
okay
it's a story
melton finch in the magic paintbrush is a flip book
it is
painting he's gonna sneeze
at you
and he draws with the paintbrush given and never doing fourth wall breaking
he's painting he's painting he's painting a door that's the door that's downstairs i saw that
the door opens and he says adieu
curious what we're gonna find downstairs then
wait up that's just as we story i was four when melton disappeared
i'm getting nervous
let's go down mom spent months searching for my brother and she sealed the doors
is there anything there's nothing special about it
i mean whatever melton had found in the house mom didn't want it getting out
they're rather strange
these are just to be in my way classic it's a metaphor in it oh don't i need that i
honestly need logic to understand how to stuff in the game
it's fine we'll just lift you up you don't need playing okay thank you because i have no upper body
strength any lake challenge give me a lake to be blamed eddie but i think louis blamed himself
after he graduated he just spent more and more time in his room until mom got him a job at the cannery
i mean some jobs can give you purpose everyone always told me to stay out of louis's room
except louis
i'm curious oh we cannot go that way don't don't think we can go that way
oh we're in a boat they used to live in a boat
it's heavy but we're doing it
he used to get high in a boat honestly
louis's room smelled very very familiar that part of him lived on past the weed past the liquor
louis spent a lot of time doing zaza i can't remember but he was surprisingly bad at them
he died a lot
you got high school diploma oh wait do you actually get that do you guys get an actual certificate
when you finish high school like this
uh we don't have this
he was so proud of being indian i think for him it was a way to oh you do all this fantastic
just a pinch oh that's cute how cute adorable i love it
oh here we go
uh
psycho institute psychology
as louis's psychiatrist i can understand your desire for an explanation as i see it the trouble
began in january shortly after we convinced your son to seek treatment for substance abuse
newly sober i believe louis first noticed the monotony of his daily life
he kept working at the canon
but he withdrew part of himself in our sessions i saw the same behavior
his mind began to
do substance abuse
i can't reach it
can't reach i shoved my hand in this oh yeah no you can touch it it's fine i'm telling you wonder
oh
i asked him to describe it
he said he started small imagining a labyrinth
he'd feel his way about
then something moved that's
and turns
it's
we've got a cape like magic to gathering
and things that have not names
he knew it was all in his head
but he took it very seriously i had hoped he'd find himself
a cheeky bit of psychosis
i can't believe playing winscape mid-game sorry guys
but he found something more
the drugs
i worried about him then
they were dreaming at the canary
i spoke with his boss
but he said louis had become a model employee
methodical tires focused
but he secretly daydream in like all the time a whole new louis
so i let him go on
is that our first mistake
i even encouraged him
it seemed very promising at first
psychosis means we can't he told me he'd made a new friend
on the edge of a city he named louis topia
he built city up slowly brick by brick
then he made musicians
and songs for them to play
he talked about starting a band
and he was always humming
every day his imagination grew stronger
he no longer spoke at the canary
everything was in his head
his chopping was as reliable as ever
then one day it struck him
it struck him
at all the cheering crowds
even the stones under his feet
more desirable than reality
so he could do whatever he wished
and he became king
he held an election for me
and he won
mario reference
they begged him to stay
but his mind was already wandering
it became a game for him
now you can see a life of the
conquer city then immediately push on
new louis
notice how the chopin's choir as well
saint louis
he started drifting away from our reality
a little bit of a crash but it's okay
no i didn't expect the wind
until one day he forgot to go home from the canary
even as his mother pleaded with him
part of louis kept sailing on
in louisburg he heard rumors of her
handsome queen wait hold on a minute
hold on a minute a pretty queen
no i'm a messed up did i do the wrong choice
the queen was on her own quest for
radiant rainbows
sorry let's try that again
sorry i ain't got that kind of action you know
he followed the sound of her
silver heart
we are literally just doing middle
earth right now sorry i said it
i'm coming my queen
his chase led him to a golden palace east of the sun and west of the moon
yeah what's inside the palace
even then his logic remained sound
we can't see nothing now
oh
there's my world was all in his imagination
i'm trying i'm trying to get rid of the difficulties on screen
proud of having created it
in his own eyes he becomes something greater than a king
that's a lot of servants or warriors
for someone who'd never known success in the real world i think it was overwhelming
and then it struck him that the real louis was not the one chopping salmon
but the one climbing the steps of the golden palace
i'm marrying his queen
hmm
my imagination is as real as my body
he told me it was hard to argue with him
so what happened
do you wonder which walker is his
why he took too much ellis
began to forget the world we know
i think it pained him to remember louis the cannery worker
did he self end the game question mark
he began to despise the man with a royal contempt
did what happens if i interact i don't know
does he sell
i still thought i could save him
oh he ends the game
even after he said he was being crowned king over all the lands of wonder
uh oh maybe the palace would be packed with his companions
maybe he doesn't
i don't i don't know how likely he doesn't but
including the wise calico and his sister don't advise him
molly
i'm enjoying the wind
his queen waited holding his crown
that guillotine
that's a guillotine
oh
oh my god
on the west i think you know
mrs finch your son was a kind man who will be missed by all of us who knew him
um
my brother was really cool i wish you could have met him
is that because of the psychedelics i heard psychedelics um ruin your brain
like they make it so you can't go back to before
the yeah i don't want her to have a baby either i don't know why she was like let's get pregnant
no maybe don't my mom told me to start packing
she waited until the day before we left to tell edie i'm not sure if she wanted to make it easier or
harder
i wish we'd stayed but i understand why we left
my mom ended up leaving everything behind
she didn't care for it
is that our father oh okay no what happened that night had been coming for a long time
what happened that maybe it should have come sooner did she hang herself
did she hang herself
i'm a little bit nervous
but it had to end one way or another
what did you do all that's left now is to tell you about that last night
wait those are the statues that come in for me
i'm scared i don't
i don't want to see my prego belly
that whole last day edie just watched his pack and didn't say a word
until supper when she raised her glass and said
to our final night together and all our final nights apart grandma you know what i said about alcohol
some of your medications are very specific i left a present for you in the hallway why don't you go open it
the grown-ups have to argue now i'm sorry you're right we're all leaving tomorrow let's just enjoy our laps
i'm not leaving edith you're excused
are you squidding me right now
the power had been shut off that morning but edie always had plenty of candles
when my mom said the library i don't think she knew about the other entrance
or that edie had a key to it
i don't think i'm gonna like what i'm saying
i'm nervous
i think you're afraid of isn't going to end when you leave the house
edith has a right to know these stories my children are dead because of your stories
i think it's best if edith and i leave tonight
we'll have the nursing home spend a van for you in the morning okay
dear edith there's so many stories i wish i could tell you but there's only time for one
this is about what happened on the night you were born
hmm that night the tide went way way out
it was the first and last time i ever saw the old house aground
there'd been an earthquake out in the middle of the ocean
they called it the lowest tide in a thousand years
god it smelled awful you know i've seen that house every day of my life
but i never thought i'd go back to it
when the fog rolled in i lost my way
i got turned around
for a while i wondered
i started seeing things
things i'd forgotten had ever existed
but when i saw them they felt like old friends that night a lot of things came back to me
or maybe i came back to them
i like the detail that is settled on the house because of the water
things i can't explain but that i need you to try and edith what are you doing in here
it's mine edith mom you're gonna rip it let go
i kicked in screen but mom's driving a car
so we're about to finish it i never saw a great grandma edie again
me the next morning the van came to pick her up but she was already gone
gone is in after that we moved around a lot
we both tried to make the best of it
a few years went by
my mom didn't like to talk about it
but she started getting sick a lot
the rest happened pretty quickly
yeah shit she got better for a while
she didn't
and then i was alone
the last inch left alive
until i found out about you
her egg was prego i'm still not sure what to tell you about all this
if we lived forever maybe we'd have time to understand things
but as it is i think the best we can do is try to open our eyes
well your family appreciate how strange and brief all of this is
is that her cervix
this journal was supposed to be for you
are we in utero
it's better not be the birth canal
it's the pregnancy is more for real
i just want to meet you and tell you all these stories myself
but i guess if you're reading this now
things didn't work out that way
she died this is where your story begins i'm sorry i won't be there to see it
it's a lot to ask but i don't want you to be sad that i'm gone i want you to be amazed
that any of us ever had a chance to be here at all good luck
you
oh my boy
that's it
i guess he really is what remains of edith's finch
um i'm sorry
right i think i think for future reference if i'm ever gonna play a sad game don't tell
me it's a sad game because i mentally shielded myself from like greeting my eyes out
and i think i over shielded myself to the point where i was like yeah i guess
is there a disgust about you
that was curious i'm not sure what i think because i have the emotional intelligence
of a camel that it didn't really hit i'm not the demographic like
but is it objectively bad no not at all not at all
and the achievement says thanks johan
yeah you cried only for seeing john wick marrying a girl without a name dying after this yeah
wait you just got here and started the game the stream and it's over uh i have terrible news yeah
um my dad is still here so i can only detour streams for a wee bit but it is over here
question i often hear you're autistic are you really yes i am does that make you love me even more
and actually you want my sweaty hands and feet on your face that was very creative very curious
um you couldn't tell literally listen to the brotherhood stream and tell me what you
tell me what you think after that okay what did anonymous say anonymous said i can understand
wanting to escape the real world and live in a fantasy where you're the hero your own story
psychedelic or not everyone wants to be seen as special yes and then just think of it
uh yes uh psychosis is such a dangerous thing to even like comprehend because what you see is
reality that other person has absolutely no perception of it is it's fascinating if you get
into it but it's actually really hard to deal with um like if you at least based on why is the
child got shot hey what's going on here oh my god it's us playing chess next week 1v1 me and chess
right now uh this room made me feel some things i need to wipe my eyes okay it is very clear the
reeflings have more emotional intelligence points than i do all my points went into luck okay i just
get super lucky in life that's where all my points went i'm low IQ low emotional intelligence low
these are childhood pictures of the creators yes what you play in chess yeah we're you next week
we're doing we're stream sniping each other in chess unironically i'm going against you guys in
chess uh yeah i cried okay reeflings definitely have more emotional intelligence than me
um
the edith finch team took him five years to spawn that the end yeah i mean that was i did not
expect the graphics at all that was like pretty insane honestly i did not expect any of that
and that was such a unique narrative storyline um all of that kind of thing going on as well
yeah i don't think i've cried at a piece of media in years oh god yours really are
leaks ahead of me and i get more sad when the dog will perish it's in a video with you
i didn't cry because you're here with me only start crying when you're in the stream real
um oh my god
it's sorry it's johnny it's a sad story but not a tear joke i could see the baby one
i'm mail off though that was really freaking sad i you just cannae leave kids unattended
at that age you just cannae i was grasping my hand the whole time during the latest segment
yeah i think he may accidentally chop it but
my eyes have been dry for over a decade
watch this while that work is a perfect background ambient we're all green though
please remember to not leave children alone yes are you getting tired me tired with my
endless stamina how dare you these accusations of being tired how dare you we're literally
doing a 12 hour endurance stream on sunday okay we're gonna finish 99 cooking and then ah i'm
gonna be all cooked up okay i did um but the endurance streams are back next week so strap in
you did you on a few seconds ago did i already i forgot okay maybe a little bit
the walking dead video game had some sad moments no i am not touching that game again
i was literally so emotionally distraught i was emotionally distraught the next day over um
the endurance streamers starting to knock the door and strap in for shorty
no i cannot go through climb again i cannot do that to myself i was ill i was ill playing that
game i'm not doing it to myself again i know there's a part two and she's all grown up but i'm too
nervous too nervous right hold on let me put on my background music and let me mute the
desktop audio well we read a few more cheeky marshmallows oh crap she'd be still away so i
can't redirect into that's it everyone's getting mandatory has to stream after straw anytime so i
can redirect into them i've been really trying baby um
is emi on later we'll just we'll just redirect into emi oh my god merci we explained this game
called mario rpg i had no idea what it was about but honestly it looked pretty good also
emi has a new ASMR up uh just so you know and a new short oh she has a short of her farting
hmm yeah oh no emi isn't streaming how dare is this right let's see if there's someone online
we can stream into hold on hold on let me cook let me cook let me cook i think i've got someone to
redirect into okay let me cook i'm cooking i'm cooking i'm farting i'm farting okay i've cooked
emi got a member stream today okay oh wait why did someone said that earlier they were like oh
there's a bit of detail in the thighs and i was like yeah on the thighs hell yeah
oh god idiot we stream every day when's the last time you took a day off um i've never
taken a day off since debut question mark i really enjoy streaming um and i enjoy having a first
time and streaming enables me to play games for the first time like i got to play suica for the
first time yesterday i got to play supermarket simulator for the first time in july i got to do
what other games did i get to play for the first time okay those were the only ones i got to play
spiral technically but i was very sick that stream so that doesn't really count um the day she takes
a day off is the day she hates us exactly balochro doesn't count no because i've got to play that
before please don't overdo it you see girl was really entertaining reminding me why the game
was injured really i thought it was about but that's just that's just my two pennies
that's just my opinion i'm getting blinded
i'm getting actually i can blinded yeah damn yeah damn right okay i've just put the dark mode on
in question as long as it's not detrimental no i will tell you if i'm freaking a perishing
and dying please don't worry i want your gross sweaty tism hands on my face so badly
stare into me stare into my eyes and tell me all about how skits so effective disorders work for
ten hours straight oh wait until i tell you about the freaking weirdest part about skits for any
medication if you stop taking the meds they will never ever work for you again it's it's bizarre
if you use them and then you get off them because you're like i'm better now i don't have
schizophrenia you can never go back onto that medication because it will never work again
for your brain brain chemistry it is bizarre just a while let's go staring to my
right should i make myself a wee bit bigger
hi giant test runny oh i'm a kraken now soon soon with my tentacles
how do you make a cut fish laugh you tend to call it
big oloshikami yeah the game finished that's not the only thing coming tonight
no okay sorry
yeah no all right okay sorry sorry hi mommy hi replaying is there any artist you would like
to get an artwork from uh no you don't have to get me artwork you silly douba you can literally
pop open that ms paint you draw your best rendition of me i'll be satisfied
was there something about a stinger oh i didn't put it on this pc some other pc
nope no stinger today sorry
literally w yeah i'm a cut fish i have different eyes as well
you can't really see it from a distance but the closer oh no the closer i get
i replay do you want to do my bedding good i'll train you well
but i also have this one no that's my hair hold on
um
but if you're being really difficult
so if you need to focus on a spiral you can you can focus on the bigger one whilst the
background one does it for you
and then there's me i'm a call fish i'm a siren that can't sing and i'm a call fish
ah i would honestly be okay and even look forward to putting your feet in my mouth
oh
it's for any it's for any good in me right now wow sky don't thank you for the super chat she's
trying to mind break us i'm not even started i'll give you a hint though the asmr stream
for next week is hypnosis themed two hours of hypnosis it's booger for you hey
hey
everything you do i love it here you did ask for a marvel of a certain persuasion
yeah i'm writing a script for the asmr stream i'm doing hypnosis live
because uh i did a really good job of doing it off the top of my head on that one stream
and then i'm being too scared to ever do it again in case people are like
the first one's so much better 20 and then i'm like uh okay well a bit off the top of my head so
hi strongy you're going to tell you a story about how you and sin used to be enemies and
they became best friends when do you plan to tell the full story when me and sin sister are playing
elden ring together it's not happening just yet but it's happening very soon or a joe game i'll
take any joe game with her i'm not sure um she she's been doing since sister's been
doing elden ring streams enemies to friends enemies to lovers but she is so good at elden
ring it's insane please press yourself against me and hold me down and tell me all about how you own
oh okay i can't read any of this i love you so my laughing cuddle i hope it doesn't feel like
mommy love readling love
um hiya strongy hi readling couldn't make the last last two days off stream and i've been
suffering from with that withdrawal itch yeah you're like this i'll bet it this accent's going
right through yeah this is this is what's key in your life but i'm getting that glorious mix of mommy
and now i just want to hold and hug and squeeze you so hard that you can't breathe and then kiss
you and tell you i love you and hugging you and at my chest and loving you and season you and
love you i feel like when i do high-pitched kisses it sounds like a an animal crossing villager like
yes we're material the other day don't be surprised how do i can't believe it
hey strongy i just wanted to be a weeb itselfish go for it when you watch your gen mate's vods can
you only share with us the timestamp the same way i would greatly appreciate not seeing the
board restreamed on your stream thank you very much for your consideration can i do that
okay i think i can do that i yeah yeah i think i can do that okay good thing you asked because
i was going to just straight up put it on my stream in the corner um it would give the girls
more views as usual yes okay mod's put the reefling in the timer box wait what did you do
Scottish and then you pronounce the t inkling language wow you do something like
you owe me 40 000 bells how are you gonna repay a reefling
i'm confused by the request oh i think it just means like it doesn't go in front of the
gameplay and stuff because i would have to layer it on top of the gameplay and then i can like
pin what the vodas were watching and like you can see the timestamp so anyone who comes in can
literally just join in you don't need to download anything because all the streams are there i get
to uh i get to do that hi stranny hi reefling you take such good care of us let's take care of
you please let your reeflings know how we can give you lots of love oh just be yourself be a happy
little reefling um and you know enjoy who you watch streaming if i might not be for you all the time
that's okay you're allowed to watch others you know right i have like five other five other
streamers i can heavily recommend plus and sister you know a just always enjoy yourself if you're
not enjoying yourself don't don't feel forced to hang around or any obligation or anything towards
me just have a good time that's all i ask i just spilled water everywhere
what is with me in liquids oh my god i was spilling cola all over me
on the mario kart stream i've just spilled water all over my oh my god
uh bro uh my freaking mouse my socks uh
all my sleeves are wet
well i'm freaking so bad oh now let me dry you off man
um big stretch i get to go in a cafe with my dad again today which i'm excited about
um
i really like when you sing lord give me one more chance
are you squiddin me right now much love
mom hello happy refling's happy thank you for the super chat i think it's a super chat it's a
super chat okay thank you for the super chat refling i'm always happy where does the ink come from
you where else would the ink come from doesn't come from me the schlick comes from me what time is
there is six a.m for me i start streams at four a.m my time the ink is made from within
hi cuddles why are you so cute oh this much adorableness has to be illegal and criminal
viola may be aloof but at this point this is just a bonus i am so unbelievably addicted to
how cute and funny you are strunny love refling love cute and funny what are you talking about
wait how would uh if i was a lollipop how would i do it
hi guys today we're going to play either pinch and um
would you still watch me if i was a lollipop
i'm one man can i put a request in for some extra kisses hmm
surprise love you love you too yes wait it's six a.m on your end well good morning yeah
i'm going to a cafe with my dad and then when i get back i have to deal with shorts because the
zur got four shorts but they're all super shorts they're all short at like 10 seconds long and i'm
like ooh that was quite the price tag to pay for those shorts gonna gonna be honest although emmy
has a new short coming out uh she was like if a if a big brother use me 400 bucks i'll show the goods
instantly a pin pal just flopped his bintas on the table and was like here's 400 and then emmy
showed her nungas uh so i'm getting that made into a shot i'm like thank you very much emmy
i'm taking that clip and i walking away with it because that was a really good clip do you plan
on doing something big before um no um there's been a few issues my dad's been a wee bit disappointed
that i don't have a lot of energy like so i sleep obviously i sleep before stream and then after
stream i go for a big sleep so he's like awake for half of the day but i sleep longer than the
average person usually so then i like only get to see him for like three hours and he's getting mad
he's getting mad yeah did you see the meme about it or she she got shared on twitter yeah well
baler is getting a clip so she can farm it as well on her channel
you should take the day off so you can hang out well we're literally going to a cafe and
we're going to do some stuff today um we made food yesterday we had chicken schnitzel i had
to check on parma he had chicken so we really went to this chicken shop and i was like yeah
i love supporting independent businesses that aren't conglomerates let's go to this chicken shop
and we got some stuff and the lady was so nice um um hope to catch you next stream oh yeah next
stream i've already forgotten hold on a little to the left i'm gonna i'm not sure i'm entertaining
enough for a little to the left speaking of a little to the left let's get the camel to out the
show um sorry that was really funny in my head i am so sorry that was that was peak comedy for my
dry ass humor sorry and i thoroughly enjoyed coming up with that well done i'm giving myself
a pat on the back there you go good job that was a good joke from me sorry i don't i don't
have good jokes all the time but i'm giving myself points for that that was a good one
um i'm giving myself points for that um now roller coaster tycoon is that ancient game that
little pixel thing with a guy like it was one guy that coded it apparently um but there might be a
slight switch up to the schedule i'm not sure yet um i'll know a bit more as time progresses as always
i'll tell you later we flinch what the deal is uh well she's a meme but she never said she was like
good one honestly my fucking humor's just awful um uh if you're fine with game suggestions always
reeflings you're more than welcome to suggest games are you squinting me right now um lass
you're probably sick of us saying this no please take a singular day off and spend it with him
before he no i'm spending the whole day you can make it up to us later if that's what you want
i'm spending the whole day that's why a little to the left apparently it's like a super short
to every game so i'm spending the whole day with him today so don't worry thank you for the super chat
and i appreciate it reluctantly sane um no we're like literally spending the whole day
don't worry i'm balanced the problem is we couldn't have known how tired i am and how busy i am with
the girls until he came over okay until he came over but now that he's here both myself and my dad
have realized wow you have no time strongy and i'm like yes yes i have no time how are you gonna
manage loving girls and stream that's uh i've already got a manager lined up don't worry don't
worry with friends like these i already have a manager lined up um but i don't need them yet
because oh my god it's a man oh yes yes yes relax previous contact good history good portfolio blah
blah blah so you don't need to worry about when if and when gen2 roll around i say if or when
mother fucker my donor funds gonna be like one dollar gen2 production confirmed
laughing at your own jokes is a symbol of mental instability what is it stop i thought that was
funny it should have been me what you want to groom you want to groom my girl yeah you want to try
and get in the discord and have open communications with them yeah is that what you want maybe if you
promise some subscriber milestones they'll show you a picture of their fanny stop that's not funny
because it actually happens in other agencies that's not funny i can't joke about that i can't joke
about that because that's actually what happens another agency sorry i can't joke about it i
can't joke about it that's what happens in other agencies so it's not funny don't laugh at that
um hey mommy hi wifling if a wifling wants to make a subbie ink video for you what would you
want to be called i don't know oh no now you're asking the real oh no this can't be
me there's an official notification discord
um what would i want to be called i think strawney's fine i like hearing strawney and
your guys's accents because like i said about zero she calls me minestrone how do we find the
discord it's only a notification discord it is pinned on veiler's twitter
it's linked in the description below i think
uh mine stronzo yeah you can call me stronzo too i like that a little nickname i as i said actually
the the girls um i already told them because the girls were designed long before the actual
girls came into pilot the mechas oh my god my immersion i'm sorry i'm i'm not the vtuber for
immersion sorry so don't listen to me close your ears close your eyes look away don't listen or
you know watch more friendly vtubers to immersion i apologize um so before um i got the pilots for
the mechas um i had already known ic me sheebie mersey isra for many months actually i have an
idea for a puzzle stream i made really cringy cringy memes of the girls that they could post
on twitter they're all pre-made but i made them before the girls came in and if we do another
puzzle reveal stream like a stream snipe thing once i get a few more things then um i might show
off the cringy memes they're so bad like they're like the worst like bitposting memes that you
could imagine um like i saw one of them yesterday in ic's file and i was like why did i make this
it's so bad um cringe memes signed me oh literally i made everyone like five memes each
and i was like you can just put this on twitter if you have nothing to say on that day and you're
not streaming um i don't it's cringe oh no it's cringe like the the fucking demon core stuff
and all that was made by me on ic's shorts and all that it's just so
um if i if you're fine with game suggestions i enjoyed fire watch and i would say only
cans because the game is hilarious i've never heard only cans i've heard of the alternatives
oh my be cringe embrace the cringe honestly but me i'm still here that's you that's the only door
don't worry you'll never be more cringe than the script master honestly he got a bulk enough
for that i got a refund got a refund for that one i assure you that much
why is the first thing i open up on twitter this are you serious hold on
why is this the first thing i see on twitter when i open it up i was just gonna check if anyone had
said anything there's no way
oh where did it go no i've broken it clearly
oh my pc just crashed uh hello
oh hold on am i pc dying
there this is the first thing i saw on twitter when i opened up thanks is there
hello hello why is there why are you put
see this is the best thing about being like you guys get to run all the social media i don't
touch it you know none of us that we are gonna dictate what you say but sometimes i have to
question what the f they're putting out come on is it what is this
shitting all by yourself handsome i bet you are taking a big job as it hits you
prostate on the way out that's disgusting stop talking can't post that can't post that and
you close that tab down real quick i saw that earlier this morning too it's an invitation
oh wait hold on i was supposed to redirect into someone is he still online
okay they're still online thank goodness i was like oh right okay i'm gonna fart no no not on
stream sorry immi farted actually speaking of immi i'm gonna very quickly pull up before it
short you guys have to you guys have to understand i paid money for this i paid money for someone to
edit immi's fart you don't understand you have to see it i'm going to link it okay you have to understand
you must understand i paid money for this and it was worth every penny you must click that link
right now so you can understand what the f i'm on about i'm watching it right now
why she was so proud uh i literally she was so proud
wait hold on let me comment on it can't can't let the gang know i fuck with this
with this and then i'll do a little skull emoji like all the fucking comment
can't let the gang know i fuck with this there we go i've just commented on it if you want to
give it a little the proudest little fatter the two honestly she got she had she must have such
like a tiny little butt if she makes like such quiet farts honestly she's got a cute little butt
i can tell i can just tell from the audio experience that she has a cute little butt
you're in streams and say we say goodbye to my family never ending
honestly stroney you can't convince me otherwise it's peak content well have an azura burp and a
sheebie burp uh short coming out i think it'll probably ship it today honestly and so both of
them are gonna have burp shorts so any burp any burp bros oh don't say you don't get fed well in
this agency i'm literally paying to get these clipped and either you're welcome if you're not
proud after a burp or a burp you'll do one day after the storm there's always thunder our little
brappy daughter rapper daughter okay right is there any more marshmallows or i think we're all
caught up yes we're all caught up there's no more marshmallows okay reefy reflins um thank you so
much for hanging out on such a unique game that was that that was an interesting experience that
was definitely very friendly for people who might not have had much experience in video games and
just wanted quite a good narrative as well it was a very unique narrative um i would say that was um
a good game personally i wouldn't replay it so i can't rank it too high wait no i need to take
out my bias sorry i forgot whenever you review games you have to take out your personal bias
and actually look at what's going on on the game and it was like straightforward gameplay
impossible to get stuck truly impossible to get stuck um very unique narrative where you need
the emotional intellect higher than a camel to understand so which is like literally the average
um uh i think it was you know good game um i'd give a what would i give it an eight out of ten
yeah i'd say comfortably an eight out of ten on the ranking and thanks for the stream mommy
thanks for the watch replay that sounds like i've stolen your watch no i promise i'm not
a kleptomaniac um we'll be here tomorrow yeah we'll play a little to the left apparently
sounds reasonable thank you shone for the stream moment we'll see you on the uh on the morrow from
mayor hell yeah thank you so much refland i'll see you goofy gibbers tomorrow as always when i redirect
into someone uh their comfort levels might not be my comfort level so just uh let let's let's uh be
a good example let's let's just show him where we can behave okay my goofy gibbers yeah refland
okay pucker up okay you're all puckered okay i'll need to get a kiss in a mo i need to get a kiss
on the mo see you goofy gibbers tomorrow and we all go and say hi to me okay see you tomorrow refland
love you